what's going on with bitcoin's price
drop recently we went for 69 000 under
58 000. what's going on there yeah it's
just uh i mean it's just the volatility
it's you know we talked about the
derivatives uh and we talked about you
know i think the dollar against these
other basket of forward currencies is
strengthening so if you're looking at
like the dixie dxy it's a dollar uh
currency index against a bunch of other
fiats um and and you know a good
argument is like yeah it doesn't really
matter because all fiats are devaluing
um but uh with the dollar as a world
reserve currency uh there is kind of
basically everybody's implicitly short
the dollar and there's so much dollar
debt out there um and so when you see
the dollar uh strengthening against
other fiats regardless if
you know cpi inflation or the money
supply is expanding the us which it is
uh you know cpi at six percent 30-year
highs regardless of that uh if the
dollar's timing against other foreign
currencies uh you know financial uh
financial conditions are tightening and
so that's that's kind of when we see you
know we haven't seen it really yet in
legacy markets but this is kind of what
leads to uh 2008 events you know march
2020 events i don't think we see a spike
that you know with that much magnitude
or that dramatic but uh you know it
could potentially be a catalyst for some
sort of risk off and i think bitcoin is
as a macro asset is reacting to that in
a way and when you think about um what
we're watching jerome powell was just uh
renominated or is going to be
renominated as the federal reserve uh
chairman is that just a continuation and
pretty bullish in terms of we're going
to continue to see interest rate
manipulation quantitative easing uh
asset prices will go to the moon uh or
do you think that there's the
possibility that even though we have the
same person running uh kind of uh the
federal reserve there may actually be
some difference in the policies that uh
that they implement yeah i think it's
more of the same i don't think i
honestly don't think powell or anyone
else really matters um i mean i don't
know what he's doing why why aren't you
just retiring and going on an island
somewhere
that i don't understand but um yeah i
mean they really don't have a choice and
they're going to go up there and jawbone
and pretend that they're switching some
sort of policy but even now i mean like
tightening or you know
tapering is is really just decreasing
the rate of of how fast they're
expanding the balance sheet it's not
even tapering in the sense of what it
used to be in a decade ago so more of
the same
rates can't rise they have to remain
negative in real terms or else the whole
system implodes and they won't say that
but that's the truth
yeah and then when you think about
bitcoin we were talking earlier uh the
number of bitcoin addresses with at
least .01 bitcoin in the balance uh hit
an all-time high over 9.2 million uh now
about nine nine point two four five
million um how do you look at something
like that in terms of the overall
picture you know we estimate that it's
either new people coming in uh or just
more and more people stacking sats and
kind of dollar cost averaging but but is
that an important metric to you or or is
it less important
yeah i mean i think that's just kind of
the trend over the last decade is that
this thing is just becoming distributed
in more and more hands um and while
addresses isn't the perfect measure
because you know i can have i can have
100 different utxos all in different
addresses and honestly for privacy best
practices um that's optimal um and so
you know you can't really see that it's
you know one entity that has multiple
utxos but essentially you know starting
with satoshi and then with with hal
finney uh and then you know two three
and now millions of people uh soon you
know seems to be billions of people all
holding bitcoin uh it's just basically
becoming more and more distributed
there's less sats uh per person to go
around and so you know that trend you
know point one bitcoin uh uh per you
know address uh one bitcoin per address
i i kind of expect that to just continue
to hockey stick up and to the right
got it and then what a general thoughts
when we saw the announcement
i think uh it's definitely it's
definitely optimistic and it's
definitely exciting um you know i
constructing a city from scratch is is
definitely ambitious um we'll see how
that goes but i think the bitcoin backed
bonds
and kind of a
bond bitcoin structure is is actually
pretty
uh it's pretty interesting in terms of
uh you know kind of a fixed income from
a fixed income standpoint i mean i i
don't want 6.5 yields and for the most
part i probably would just buy bitcoin
um but you know for for a lot of these
uh you know maybe if you're a fund
manager i don't know if they're going to
be allowed to allocate to this
institutional capital but i know there
are a lot of bitcoiners that would you
know fork over some money to secure
citizenship secure some upside with
bitcoin and
uh you know kind of just fun something
that they that they believe in um and
it's really exciting just from a you
know a bigger picture standpoint like
the jurisdictional arbitrage the kind of
sovereign individual thesis where where
nations where governments are competing
for citizens and competing for capital
um kind of the opposite trend that we've
seen where
you know governments are trying to
you know almost trap their their
citizens trap the capital uh it's it's
exciting and i think that's what that's
what bitcoin kind of brings to the world
and seeing you know these first dominoes
fall is is really really exciting
yeah what's fascinating about it is if
there are institutions that want to buy
bonds but they can't uh and so this is a
way for or i'm sorry they have to buy
bonds they can't buy bitcoin this is a
way for them to buy bonds but get some
underlying bitcoin exposure very similar
to a bunch of folks who were allocating
uh to microstrategy and their uh
unsecured notes right you could
basically get some uh exposure there or
you could buy microstrategy stock and
get some indirect exposure to bitcoin
almost like this tracking stock uh for a
period of time um is your thought
process that like that's really who's
going to be buying this or do you think
it's really going to be bitcoiners like
do you think it will be more uh folks
that understand bitcoin and they want to
see this happen and therefore they'll go
ahead and they'll buy this even though
they could buy bitcoin if they wanted to
yeah i think i think it'll probably be a
mix of both i mean i i haven't um i've
talked with some people but haven't you
know had too many high level discussions
on this more just kind of gauging the
sentiment on twitter and reading the
official kind of block stream posts and
and what you know b kelly is saying but
i think you know from from a kind of uh
like a securitization standpoint and
like a digital asset standpoint i think
maybe that's a little overhyped when
people say just through around the world
digital assets like
um yeah it's kind of
a buzzword in a way but uh i think like
kind of being on on native uh bitcoin
rails uh with you know the liquid
network and what it's uh i think they're
teaming up with biffin x i think these
notes will probably be trading just like
a you know another crypto asset and so
that's kind of from a from a you know
finance or econ lens um it's it's
exciting to see all this kind of unfold
because um you know this sort of
innovation and maybe i hope it will be
somewhat seamless in the sense that you
know these things are just trading 24 7
365 like you know these other assets um
that's exciting and the ability to you
know kind of custody these uh these
notes and have a maybe a bitcoin income
stream
is pretty cool